y después efectivamente será una semana
bastante cargada de actividades para
demorar más juan manuel ma con quien
pasó la noche en la lopd edad honesto es
en versalles y es la casa de descanso de
la presidente de la red pública se
espera que hoy oa más tardar mañana pues
esté de regreso aquí al elíseo esta
semana pues justamente este miércoles
será el consejo de ministros el que
puede ser y de sería ya el último
consejo de ministros de este gobierno en
especial del primer ministro ron castex
porque se espera que para el fin ya de
esta semana ya sea jueves o viernes una
vez el consejo constitucional haya ya
proclamados los resultados de esta
segunda vuelta pues
éste intervenga pues ya la dimisión de
este gobierno es algo que se realiza
tradicionalmente y luego ya de manuel
mccomb pues nombraré ya un nuevo
gobierno un nuevo primer ministro se
habla mucho de que podría ser una nueva
primera ministra y esto sería ya para la
próxima semana así que como ustedes ven
una semana bastante cargada para de
manuel marco teniendo en cuenta además
que el primer mandato de la nueva comba
hasta el próximo 13 de mayo